[Music]
[Applause]
no Michelle akin finally got it I refer
to you as Michelle Vargas to everyone
else did I talk sorry without you but
I'm letting them know that that's not
officially her last name anymore
akin then she was a Vargas I'm at my
side down and I slept here last night in
her office and that was just staring me
in the face I was like oh man those are
the promo photos for the first ever to
woman comedy show that we did grace
Michelle's sleepover yeah after we
graduated college and move to Brooklyn
together this is the dog that we got in
Brooklyn when we live together dog and
then when we move to Michelle's much
better at taking care of dogs that was
got a car sick every time I tried to
take him in a taxi back to my bed he
just needed some stability yeah and I
was not ready to offer that to him at
that point in its life and he's an old
man now
yeah hello sir you thought she wasn't
gonna remember you it was like Reese
came home from war I was so sweet I
can't couldn't believe it it's like it
was a big wiggle fest on both sides just
to give you guys back so if you don't
know Michelle and I started YouTube
channel together when we graduated
college in 2008 hello grace sent me an
email that I need to find that says we
don't need cameras we can use the webcam
I neck and I was like brilliant
is a video editor as one of her Jack of
mini trade so we would shoot videos and
edit them before we knew what YouTube
was and what every other opportunities
that it could have
we just had separate jobs to live
together so at the end of the day we
would drink a glass of wine and quack in
the camera and then one of us would edit
together and we used it when we first
started we would put them up on our
separate YouTube KS so there's a whole
bunch on your done
she's here I'm here there's a whole
bunch on this Bush 21 we're not drunk
yet we just opened the wine that's weird
and disjointed I mean what I want to
blog press we had a blog press that's
not a lot of go but I let the URL go by
the way I figure that's for the best
grace to Michele calm it's available
there's some friends out there things
great super Shelly we wanted do this I
remember when we knew you well we
decided to make a youtube channel
together instead of posting on the
individual channels I thought we were
the biggest geniuses of all time yeah I
was like we're moguls we're doing this
and then we got into the partner program
and we could finally monetize our videos
we would make like five dollars a month
but we thought it'd be really fun while
I'm here to do a good old-fashioned
roundup really round it up yeah oh my
god that's Lucas tell Jay Bell these are
basically just a hodgepodge of things
that we've been up to I mean what then
but you've got some major stuff going on
yeah like I went to the Taylor Swift
concert yeah big round right there with
my friend Joplin feeling like the third
row
[Music]
it was a good life moment any matter I
know this year not this year the last
there's like a count out like one hand
how many times I've been jealous of
grace and that's one of them I also went
to the toes of bouncer hey you live in
this new apartment in Jersey again no
circle the roots are strong here and
also here I had a child that took up a
good amount of the last three years of
my life yeah and I met the child from
yes and I and the child really enjoys
coloring with ain't grace and she's
coughed in my face a few times this
morning good you're gonna have a real
connection to her also I got a dog I was
in a band for a minute oh yeah glues Ram
look at that boys yeah tower top bunk
the three-piece yeah we had four shows
before we broke up I made a bunch of
denim jackets that I'm giving to my
family this year which is really special
like the baby that you had taken up a
lot of my time I won NaNoWriMo what is
it a were that national novel writing
contest oh oh right fifty thousand or
more words in the month my certificate
that I get out at home but I mean that's
a little sad your newfound hobby so
Michelle there hasn't been like super
close but then you reached out a couple
months ago we're like hey can we start
talking more I know we don't live
together maybe like once a week we can
like Skype or talk or something I was
like that's perfect actually could
really use someone to talk to you been
consistently doing that these two
flopping muppet idiots we are
consistently and making a time the
originated that consistently
inconsistent phrase yeah we are
consistently inconsistent and you love
it
even when we have to cancel we
reschedule we reschedule and get
accountants I got on the phone with you
once or in the video thing and I was
like so it started Harry Potter
fanfiction and you freaked out I was
like you've been reading it the whole
time
so in fact the reason I haven't been
reading fanfiction all this time is
because one of you goobers wrote some
about us what oh yeah
freak me out and I just put fanfictions
in a category that is not okay yeah I
think it's very very creative just when
I've had stuff written about me and my
friends that I have very you know
heterosexual that's what I get a little
like I don't like it when it's written
about real people but I got totally into
it if it's about characters so I've been
writing Harry Potter fanfiction yeah
what's up drew Miami fandom
I'm very into the Draco Malfoy Hermione
Granger relationship the good girls go
for bad boys it's my marriage Ron
Weasley but the fantasy though I've been
writing under the pseudonym lily and
silver oh yeah because I'm a bit of a
weirdo I did a photo shoot for my
pseudonym it's the coolest photo ever
also Halloween Eric Michael Pearson I'll
link all of her stuff down there so you
guys can go read it and check it out
because people's interests are piqued I
read some really amazing stuff from
other people and after a week of reading
other people's [ __ ] I was just like I
eat right shout out to my two favorite
writers Oh give him some recommend a
lotta love spit cut eight what's up
what's up am something than you I hope
I'm saying your name right every time we
get on a bed called your life I wrote
know they're like fifty billion words
I'm like I watch another episode of Real
Housewives that I owe a lot of this to
you though because I I said something
that grace like I'm really look like
thinking I'm talking a lot about getting
back in my creative fashion she was like
you like to talk about it I was like
excuse me miss but that was very helpful
I was like you're right and I went and
wrote my ass off yeah you're welcome
I mean I need to take my own advice
right now whatever men I've been
coaching the creative people around
getting their art out into the world for
the past seven years and this was my
first big like for a back into doing
something creative and really being
engulfed by it and turns out the words
are just pouring out of you like
diarrhea yes Mexican restaurant exactly
like yeah and you can playing piano
right there I've put up some Instagram
videos good girls do
[Music]
so check that out I have a piano in my
house I look at some time to think about
playing bang on it how are you spending
your New Year's my sister's house she's
having a party oh yeah
Mongol their house is here it's lovely
yeah I live ten minutes from my oldest
sister now which is this kiss in the
mouth can we still say that but we the
things that we used to do is that really
we probably can't do anymore a lot of
things probably I want to say I'm more
year while we did trip down memory lane
[Music]
right now I'm not drunk okay your
daughter I like tips your job your truck
[Music]
you watch please my resolution is stop
being a lazy [ __ ] the dog is shaking
[ __ ] wow we did a lot he did that that
was all back in two thousand eight nine
ten mmm
before all this shenanigans and all
these young kids are doing I'll be
precise we're all speaking of young
Miller should we introduce again Oh
Amelia my kids okay
the creature that came out of her womb
she's very very cute she likes to do art
with me
but it's very very cute this the
intentions are fair always and bad it's
stalling for time when Michelle left
videos in the past okay who do we have
here you guys
oh look at these ooh there's a camera
look this is the cutest yeah yeah point
at them and tell them that they're not
if they're not subscribed that they
shouldn't they should read your mom's
smutty fanfic yeah every mom's nut he
said hi look she's already looking at
herself in the viewfinder she's gonna be
a great a blogger one day yeah well this
is Amelia not really a word ugh I
demonstrate you see that was a
reenactment of what she did this
possibly fail her cousins there'd be pot
a little some something some face
arrived yesterday and I immediately came
down with 102 feet okay yeah I've been
here less than an hour
I can't she's very demanding cheating
out your leaving you this is the one
time you actually don't want to be part
of whatever it is someone else's do it I
don't know what she wants the sign of a
good mom
I feel like we've sufficiently rounded
up I think we have I mean excuse single
word to if you follow us on social yeah
yeah just follow us where are all your
socials not
instagrams Michele Lake and 21 and
everywhere else toast Michele Eakins and
Lily and silver stuff on tumblr
oh yeah you post every week right I post
a twice a week on my my work in progress
right now okay all the links again will
be done in the scripture box below thank
you guys for watching if you're not
subscribed do so already
I should have probably told you let's do
the bail notification thing this is I
mean this won't be here in future videos
so take it in while you can down
she's actually pretty enamored of buying
her own entertainment value like her mom
oh my god oh my god this ed don't hate
kids it turns out yeah yeah I had a
breakthrough